[Música]
ya son más de 500.000 las personas que
han muerto en brasil a causa del hobbit
19 el gigante suramericano es el segundo
país del mundo y alcanzar el medio
millón de muertos después de eeuu desde
ciudadanos protestaron contra el
gobierno del presidente ya ir bolsonaro
a quien culpan de minimizar el impacto
de la pandemia tenemos reporte
este domingo en francia 48 millones de
ciudadanos están convocados a las urnas
para renovar las asambleas regionales y
departamentales los comicios que medirán
la fuerza de la extrema derecha y que
son vistos como una antesala de las
presidenciales programadas para abril de
y cada 20 de junio se conmemora el día
mundial de los refugiados declarado a
partir de 2001 por la organización de
las naciones unidas el objetivo de la
fecha generar conciencia acerca de las
problemáticas que enfrentan en los más
de 80 millones de personas que viven
bajo condiciones de refugio o
desplazamiento tenemos análisis
continuamos con más información de
américa latina y del mundo aquí en las
24 mi nombre es lydia na valencia
iniciamos en brasil porque la cifra de
muertos por kobe 19 sobrepasó el medio
millón es el segundo país del mundo en
superar las 500 mil víctimas sólo por
detrás de eeuu este sábado se vivió una
jornada de protestas pidiendo la salida
del presidente ya ir bolsonaro desde río
de janeiro nuestra corresponsal valeria
saccone con los detalles
para zizou pero anoche la triste marca
de los 500.000 muertos causados por el
cob y 19 y en esos momentos suma el 25
por ciento de todos los fallecimientos
causados por esta enfermedad en todo el
planeta hasta la fecha tan sólo un país
los estados unidos superaron este récord
macabro pero hay que recordar que hay a
la población es un 55 por ciento más
grande que aquí en brasil mientras los
políticos y la sociedad siguen divididos
sobre las medidas a seguir para intentar
contener esta pandemia fuera de control
por un lado los epidemiólogos advierten
de que se acerca una posible tercera ola
que podría ser más mortífera que las
anteriores y de hecho hay cálculos que
estiman que brasil podría alcanzar los
750 mil muertos en el mes de septiembre
las recomendaciones de los expertos son
distanciamiento social y seguir usando
la mascarilla de forma preventiva sin
embargo el presidente y jair bolsonaro
parece ir en la dirección opuesta como
ha dicho a lo largo de toda la pandemia
recientemente ha propuesto que no sea
obligatoria la mascarilla para aquellos
que se vacunaron o que ya superaron la
enfermedad
en brasil tan sólo el 11 por ciento de
la población recibió las dos dosis de la
vacuna de momento la comisión
parlamentaria que investiga la gestión
de la pandemia está investigando
activamente para descubrir si jair
bolsonaro y sus asesores quisieron
diseminar de forma consciente la
enfermedad para poder alcanzar la
llamada inmunidad de rebaño
en perú la autoridad electoral revisa
las impugnaciones y nulidades
solicitadas por la candidata derecha
keiko fujimori razón por la cual no se
ha proclamado oficialmente al maestro
pedro castillo como nuevo presidente los
partidarios de cada uno de los bandos se
tomaron las calles de lima este sábado
informes de rosa pérez
la polarización que vive perú se reflejó
este sábado en las calles de lima dos
semanas después de las elecciones
peruanas seguidores del candidato de
izquierda pedro castillo y de la ultra
conservadora keiko fujimori salieron a
defender respectivamente su apoyo a los
candidatos con todas las actas
procesadas el maestro sindicalistas sumó
el 50 a 125 por ciento de los apoyos es
decir 44 mil votos más que fujimori
quien sin pruebas hizo públicas
denuncias de fraude las que respaldan
sus simpatizantes e impugnó cientos de
actas que la autoridad electoral sigue
revisando lo peor de la humanidad
por nuestro país no se trata de cálculo
se trata del pelo
hasta el abismo
al mismo tiempo en la plaza 2 de mayo
del centro de la ciudad se manifestaron
los apoyos al maestro castillo en la
llamada marcha nacional o
lamentablemente la señora es una
corrupta que no debería estar no me va a
aceptar a la ropa que ganó aquí lo que
gano es la democracia
el gesto voto del pueblo quizá del
pueblo levantado todas las regiones y
protestando en contra de la señora keiko
que ni siquiera ha llegado al 49 por
ciento en protesta en contra los señores
y jurado nacional de elecciones que
hasta el momento no lo proclama como
presidente de la república al maestro
pedro castillo de ron es la autoridad
electoral y anunció el 16 de junio que
no proclamará el presidente del país
para el período 2021 2026 hasta que haya
analizado todas las impugnaciones aunque
de momento la mayoría han sido
desestimadas
este domingo los franceses van a las
urnas para renovar las asambleas
regionales y departamentales en 13
territorios metropolitanos y 5 de
ultramar estos comicios son vistos como
una antesala de las elecciones
presidenciales que se disputarán en
abril del año entrante pero que son las
asambleas regionales y departamentales y
qué autoridad tienen veamos en este
informe francia está dividida en 95
departamentos cada uno con su propia
asamblea departamental a pesar de
cumplir una función importante muchos
votantes franceses no tienen ni idea de
lo que hacen la respuesta a los pasos
no lo sé me imagino que todo esto está
perfectamente escrito en alguna parte
elegidos cada seis años las asambleas
departamentales tienen varios roles y
responsabilidades importantes están a
cargo de las escuelas intermedias el
mantenimiento de las vías las
bibliotecas y museos y el departamento
de bomberos también cumplen una función
social clave proporcionando subsidios a
las ong y están a cargo de varios
programas de ayuda financiera y vivienda
más conocidas por los votantes las
asambleas regionales de francia
funcionan de la misma manera pero a
nivel regional sus responsabilidades
incluyen el desarrollo económico
regional
por ejemplo proporcionando ayuda
financiera y subsidios para las empresas
el transporte el establecimiento de
estrategias territoriales y
medioambientales y supervisar las
escuelas secundarias y la formación
profesional a pesar de su importancia
los votantes franceses tienden a pasar
por alto las elecciones regionales y
departamentales en 2015 ambas encuestas
registraron tasas de participación de
alrededor del 50%
también en armenia se vive hoy una
jornada de elecciones legislativas
anticipadas las encuestas muestran una
contienda codo a codo entre el primer
ministro nicole pajín jean y su rival el
ex presidente robert kocharián esto en
el contexto de la reciente derrota
militar del país contra su vecino
azerbaiyán en por la disputada región de
nagorno karabaj a los detalles con
nuestra corresponsal en ereván beatriz
arslanián
pasaron ocho meses desde el fin de la
última guerra de henao
en el cual se intensificó la atención
política como así también la
polarización social en el país
esto hoy se celebran elecciones
parlamentarias anticipadas en las que 26
partidos y fuerzas políticas disputan
las bancas de la asamblea nacional
las encuestas las facciones que lideran
estas elecciones son la coalición
armenia encabezada por el ex presidente
robert kocharián y el partido
oficialista contrato cívico del primer
ministro interino en nicole pazzini
estas facciones deben obtener por lo
menos el 51 por ciento de los votos por
lo contrario habría posibilidades de una
segunda vuelta por otro lado es
importante mencionar la significativa
cantidad de ciudadanos indecisos en
trajes
y asciende al 30% y otros que han
decidido no
a las 8 de la mañana
establemente a pesar de las renuncias de
ciertas y regula
que ocurrieron en los colegios
electorales por un momento alrededor de
un 20% de la población ejerció su
derecho al voto y aquellos que no lo
hicieron pueden hacerlo hasta los 20 del
horario local
este domingo 20 de junio se conmemora el
día mundial del refugiado declarado por
las naciones unidas a partir del año
2001 cada año la cifra de refugiados a
nivel mundial aumenta y también los
posibles abusos que estas personas
sufren al salir de sus territorios desde
la agencia de la onu para de los
refugiados acnur y distintas
asociaciones se intenta aprovechar la
fecha para generar más conciencia sobre
esta problemática la onu estima que más
de 80 millones de personas están
refugiadas una cifra que incluye 45,7
millones de desplazados internos 29,6
millones de desplazados por la fuerza de
sus países y 4,2 millones de
solicitantes de asilo y representa el 1
por ciento de la humanidad para analizar
esta información nos comunicamos con
olga cerrado moore vocera de acnur para
las américas bienvenida a france 24 y
cuéntenos con temor a nuestra audiencia
la diferencia entre refugiado migrante
desplazado y asilado y la importancia
que tiene esta fecha para promover
políticas a favor de los derechos de
estas personas
hola buenos días bueno pues hoy es una
fecha en la cual conmemoramos ese coraje
esa valentía de las personas refugiadas
y desplazadas en el mundo y también es
una oportunidad pues para hacer un
llamado a los líderes mundiales para que
trabajen en solucionar las causas del
desplazamiento los conflictos que
obligan a las personas a salir cuál es
la diferencia entre una persona
refugiada a migrantes solicitantes de
asilo
las personas refugiadas son personas que
no tienen otra opción más que salir de
sus países para sobrevivir porque han
sido víctimas de persecución por su por
su raza por su orientación sexual por su
orientación política y las personas
solicitantes de asilo no pueden volver a
su país los países tienen la obligación
internacional de acoger a estas personas
ya que volver a sus países supondría
un temor un riesgo para su vida las
personas solicitantes de asilo son
personas que han solicitado esa
protección internacional pero que de
momento están esperando a una resolución
por parte de los países de acogida bueno
pero si bien este es el día del
refugiado también la problemática se
vive todos los días en todos los países
y también deriva muchas veces en actos
de xenofobia o discriminación hacia los
refugiados de que vale la acnur está
promoviendo el respeto por estas
personas
es importante darse cuenta de que cuando
un país abre las puertas a un refugiado
lo que hace es salvarle la vida
que nadie quiere salir de su país que
salen de su país por obligación y con
muchas ganas de construir de recomenzar
su vida
desde acnur trabajamos muy de cerca con
las comunidades de acogida de estas
personas refugiadas del 82,4 millones de
personas que comentabas el 20 por ciento
están en américa latina' en la región de
las américas y estas son las regiones
más solidarias del mundo con los
refugiados y con las personas
desplazadas pero obviamente es
importante que la comunidad
internacional apoye a las comunidades
que los sacó claro que en gran medida en
la mayoría de las ocasiones son personas
que también tienen muchas necesidades
por supuesto y como promover una
política migratoria internacional más
justa que le permita a las personas de
todos los países migrar en condiciones
seguras sin arriesgar su vida
recurriendo a caminos ilegales
rápidamente por favor
es importante buscar soluciones
alternativas como por ejemplo hemos
visto en colombia en febrero que se puso
en marcha un estatuto temporal de
protección lo mismo están haciendo otros
países también buscar soluciones para
facilitar la reunificación familiar y
sobre todo asegurarse que esas rutas que
se toman son seguras que se que se
identifican las necesidades de
protección de las personas que llegan a
las fronteras para evitar que se vean
expuestos a los riesgos de usar pasos
irregulares pues es olga cerrado moore
vocera de acnur para las américas de las
por estar en 324 y cambiamos de
información porque eeuu celebró por
primera vez el jumping como un feriado
nacional luego de que el presidente joe
biden así lo dispusiera con eventos
académicos perfomances desfiles y música
los estadounidenses especialmente los
afroamericanos se hablaron el día en que
se conmemora el fin de la esclavización
en 1865
lo que era reconocido hace más de 150
años se celebró por primera vez este 19
de junio como un feriado a nivel
nacional con desfiles música y baile los
estadounidenses conmemoraron en jumping
la fecha que recuerda el 19 de junio de
1865 cuando se le avisó a los últimos
afroamericanos esclavizados en galveston
texas que habían sido liberados dos años
atrás por orden del entonces presidente
abraham lincoln
es importante que sea un día festivo
porque reconoce las luchas y la
perseverancia de nuestros antepasados y
ese día de la libertad para ellos
el de este año tiene mayor peso se da
pocos días después de que el presidente
joe biden lo convirtiera en un festivo
federal y justo un año después de la
muerte de georg floyd el afroamericano
que perdió la vida bajo custodia
policial y desató el movimiento contra
el racismo más grande del siglo 21 como
parte de las celebraciones una estatua
de georges lloyd fue presentada en
brooklyn
y esta estatua transmite la fuerza y la
dignidad de georges floyd esperó que
impulse a los electores los residentes y
los transeúntes a continuar
organizándose movilizándose marchando y
educándose con el objetivo de un cambio
activo
james el jumping como feriado nacional
supone un espaldarazo para la comunidad
afro en eeuu pero no borra el hecho de
que aún quedan muchas batallas por
librar sobre todo en términos de
igualdad
así finalizamos por esta emisión
entradas 24 porque ustedes pueden
continuar con más en france 24 punto com
quédense con nosotros
[Música]